I'm definitely gonna get diabetes after
this when I think of American cereal I
just think of sugar just plain sugar I'm
so excited to try this I've been waiting
years for this I'm ready yeah let's do
this
happen yeah what happened to the tan
captain it's cutting cut and crunch
doesn't smell like anything it's weirdly
boring
it's like glazed with sugar which I find
is awesome they really do taste like
Cheerios this kind of reminds me of when
I was a kid and had cornflakes you would
put the sugar on but with this you kind
of need to take some sugar out
this isn't cereal these are cookies why
did you give me cookies in a bowl not
bad it doesn't really taste like a
cookie though this is nutrigrain but
it's got choc chip cookies in it no need
to give Santa like a big glass of milk
and a giant cookie instead of just give
him a bowl of this I'm not a fan
the other thing American was just
running out of ideas they just chucked a
bunch of cookies in a box and hold it
cereal huh but I'm not a big fan of
racist peanut butter cups that's too
intense
and now it's in cereal they look like
giant cocoa balls they remind me of pet
food or rabbit poop it tastes so good
but I think I shouldn't like it this is
like a hollow KitKat I like peanut
butter but I don't think it belongs in
cereal this is like a sad cereal I'd
probably have this after a breakup so
can I take this box home with me because
I'm done I've never heard of this before
like what is cinnamon toast crunch
these look like brainwaves you can
actually smell the cinnamon lip tastes
like Christmas
cinnamon Scrolls at Kohl's you could buy
yeah yeah it tastes exactly like
cinnamon toast which is awesome and then
it's mixed with milk it's makes it even
better
mmm so this I expected doughnuts these
are not doughnuts these are better than
doughnuts no there's something good
about how simple this is I appreciate
that I would happily move to America
just for cinnamon toast crunch Trix are
for kids I don't understand why I have a
rainbow in my bowl all I thought was
nerds in milk this is like Froot Loops
but on crack hands down I could buy this
for breakfast I could buy this for lunch
and dinner as well
would you have this again uh
no I wouldn't mr. Prime Minister get
these on our shelves right now Lucky
Charms what is it
marshmallow in there why do you have
marshmallows in your cereal yeah that's
just wheat America it's one of those
cereals that you put in the car do you
mom says get it out yeah oh it's so
slimy too Oh No that's it yeah no I'm
good for them this is more of a dessert
than a breakfast the marshmallows in the
Lucky Charms are like the Beyonce in
Destiny's Child take them away and it's
nothing the cereal isn't the greatest by
not means well because hey there's
rainbows in here so it's progressive
after today I think American cereal was
exactly what I thought it was colorful
sugary and diabetes America you've set
the bar for out there cereals and the
rest of the world has a lot to live up
to I'm on the sugar rush of my life
right now so thank you for that America
I feel as if Australian cereal is Lil
Wayne but American cereal is jay-z